[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt nun ganz
spezielles rezept von mir wir machen
einen leckeren schokoladenkuchen aus der
pfanne wochen keinen backofen und ich
habe mir gesagt wenn ich schon mal so
ein rezept mache dann braucht ihr auch
keine küchenwaage also das ist wirklich
ein rezept für all diejenigen die
wirklich null equipment zum backen haben
aber trotzdem leckeren kuchen haben mich
zum beispiel für westdeutsche studenten
schüler leute die einfach kein backofen
haben warum meine schwester hatte zum
beispiel auch ganz lange keinen backofen
und musste dann auch mal zu sehen also
ich fand direkt an
ich schreibe euch alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben unten in die box infobox
so ich starte jetzt übrigens habe ich
mir gedacht dass ich das jetzt auch
keine waage benutze es gibt ja auch das
auch in der türkei zum beispiel gab es
typisch dass man da so gläser zum essen
nimmt ich habe mir gedacht ich nehme
einfach so eine joghurt verpackung 150
gramm die kennt die bestimmte im
viererpack hierzu verkauft haben die
nämlich jetzt als maß das heißt ich
werde jetzt einmal den inhalt direkt in
meine fahne entleeren und das nehme ich
dann halt die ganze zeit als mass ihr
könnt übrigens auch gerne alles in eine
schüssel tun und dann verrühren wenn ihr
in weniger empfindliche fahne habe bei
mir das jetzt nicht so daher mache ich
es direkt hier drin und sparen wir dann
nochmal geschirr
so gebe ich jetzt kurz zur seite
ich geb war direkt schon mal die eier
mit dazu vanille extrakt gebe ich jetzt
auch schon direkt mit dazu das ist
natürlich nicht so für im lot besser
wissen müsste ein teelöffel das kann man
ja ganz gut wie mal daumen sondern sogar
mehl und backpulver also diese ganzen
sehr trockenen zutaten die werde ich
sieben damit es dann halt noch feiner
wird und keine klümpchen da drin sind so
damit man damit man es besser dosieren
kann so einen teil becher mail
jetzt kommt unser papa kauder ist ganz
wichtig dass er nicht trinken sondern
wirklich den starken tönen zeige ich
euch jetzt auch noch mal weil da bekomme
ich immer wieder die nachfrage ob da
ganz normaler körper mit gemeint ist
aber der ist wirklich zum backen gar
naja könnt ihr natürlich auch ein cacau
draus machen mit milch und zucker aber
ich muss den hut immer zum backen so
erreicht aber schon ein halber becher
mit und parallel gebe ich noch ein
teelöffel backpulver mit dazu
[Musik]
so jetzt fahre ich erst mal und gibt
dann nach und nach das sonnenblumenöl
mit dazu so nachdem jetzt alles
miteinander verrührt ob das dort
wirklich nur eine minute ist übrigens
auch ein sehr sehr schnelles rezept weil
wir müssen jetzt fast gar nichts weiter
tun außer das ganze natürlich auf den
herd stellen
ich habe jetzt hier noch meint aber da
nehme ich jetzt so die oberen ränder
noch mal ein bisschen runter ach guck
mal hier sieht man weiß schon noch
temperatur ist wirkt schon is back schon
eigentlich könnte man das jetzt noch
bleibt verstreichen aber die masse hat
sich jetzt ganz von alleine verteilt ich
habe jetzt hier hat prix mittlere stufe
auf meinem hertha geht jetzt den deckel
drauf ich muss auch dazu sagen wenn er
zur fahne besitzt die schon sehr also wo
sie die sachen sehr anpacken und die
keine gute beschichtung habt dann müsst
ihr sie vorher auf jeden fall mit
ordentlich butterfett mit richtig viel
mehl aussteigen weil sonst ärger durch
nachlass bei meiner freunde ist das
jetzt natürlich nicht notwendig ich habe
jetzt auch im deckel wo kein loch drin
bist du gibst mir diese deckel mit
diesem ja wo halt noch diese dieses loch
vorhanden ist wenn ihr so einen deckel
habt dann bitte auch mit dem stück
alufolie verschließen weil das muss
jetzt komplett ohne luft verschlossen
sein
und jetzt müssen wir erstmal gar nichts
weiter tun einfach nur abwarten konnten
ja abwarten und latte macchiato trinken
30 minuten hat das ganze jetzt gedauert
und wir machen jetzt auch noch die
stäbchen probe aber ihr werdet euch
wundern wie toll dass sie in dieser
fahne aussieht
ich würde so gut ich finde das sieht
einfach nur sagt dich aus der rein damit
und es bleibt nichts hängen das heißt
der ist auf jeden fall durch gegart ist
auch eine tolle form muss ich sollen
jetzt werde ich das auch ganz einfach
aus der pfanne rauskriegen ich habe sie
vorher wie gesagt nicht gefettet stürzt
sich das oder mache ich es für husum
omelett nicht stütze war
nicht klappen grade wie ein babypopo
stick oder soll ich so genannten haben
sagt aber ich mach doch eh schoko show
coding stripper ist doch schön oder das
glas ist für das also dass ich bin stolz
dann lassen wir diese so okay das ist
jetzt sehr auf meine schieferplatte
begeisterte sind sogar auf ich glaube
ich eine andere platte das ist so
verloren auf der großen schieferplatte
immer unsere probleme behind the scenes
vw zu diskutieren auf welche platte
hintergund schöne kuchen kommt mache ich
erstmal ein schokokuss und der geht ganz
einfach ich nehme hier einfach
puderzucker 3 ist so viel puderzucker
adresse für bacau das ganze mit 150
milliliter sahne
warum soll ich jetzt die ganzen kram
angaben dazu habe ich jetzt sage 3 ist
dafür schon rein gemacht war das jetzt
das vom 3 ja auf jeden fall verrückt das
miteinander und dann ist das ein richtig
schönes schoko topping und es gibt so
schnell also nur zusammen können dann
obendrauf geben ich dekoriere das heute
übrigens auch noch mit früchten und noch
mal mit ein bisschen schokolade
[Musik]
dann bekommt das so pfannkuchen eine
ganz andere bedeutung
einfach einen pfannkuchen eierkuchen
das ist doch bedeutet jetzt mach
pfannkuchen suchen so suchen die
eigentlich fand kuchen
da suchen wir einen pfannkuchen ja ein
kuchen der fahne weil ich gerade sagen
gut dass mich dreckig gemacht
diese umstände offen
[Musik]
ganz ehrlich gesagt schmecken ich habe
angst gehabt so ich muss ehrlich sein
ich mir gut und ich bin auch diese also
auf diese obere schicht nach dieser show
also besteht kein jahr verzichten weil
das ist dieses zusammenspiel das lecker
macht finde ich auch so da also die
diese klausel oben die muss sein wenn
die nicht wäre
da wird das nicht merken also wird das
hat nicht so gut und habe noch eine
anmerkung wir haben wir jetzt so laut
war mit dem dk so verziert das hat
bewegt dass sie so ein bisschen schmilzt
was ich richtig aber man kann auch kalt
genießen machen die klausel auch nach
dem erkalten drauf machen dann bleibt
die auch so fest aber ich bin so viel
besser und der kuchen also diese
brauchen angefahren auf jeden fall der
ist auch nicht so defensiv an die süße
auf mehr
ich glaube der kette ein bisschen mehr
zucker vertragen ja wir werden deine
infoboxen ganzen welcher zucker
schreiben weil ich hätte nur 34 dollar
store versorgen haben und die leute die
mir zu können wollen sondern dazu drei
machen das wirklich an ich also ich habe
drei vier richtig gut und vor allem
positiv überrascht perfekte lösung wir
wünschen euch viel spaß und nach machen
schreibt mir unbedingt wir das was
empfindet und wenn ihr noch mehr solche
rezepte sehen möchte wenn er sagt ich
habe dieses nicht
weil jenes nicht dass noch was einfallen
das ist schreibt in die kommentare ich
also wieder was einfallen
und ja sagen
[Musik]